So I saw your Harry Potter and Hunger Games
sins videos.
Yeah?
Read the books, asshole!
So you’re saying that any movie based on
a book, I need to read the book first?
Yeah.
Okay, All the President’s Men.
That movie’s based on a book, and I’ve
never read it, but that movie’s awesome.
You wanna know why?
Cause they explain everything.
And that movie’s entertaining.
And it’s better than Harry Potter and Hunger
Games.
Combined.
You’re comparing one of the most important
political stories of our time to fantasy novels?
Now, let’s just say the movie All the President’s
Men didn’t explain everything, maybe there’s
a phone call or a clandestine parking lot
meeting, but we don’t get to see it.
But all the sudden Woodward & Bernstein know
all this sh*t about Watergate but we didn’t
see how they learned it.
Right, now you would sit there and tell me
to go read the book.
Well, what I’d probably say—
Or you’d say, “Don’t worry about it,
you can figure it out in five seconds if you
just think about it.”
Well, sure, I can figure out that somebody
told them.
Somebody probably that worked at the White
House.
But if I don’t know who it is, if I don’t
understand their
They make movies like Harry Potter for people
who read the books.
Bullsh*t.
Studio guys would throw themselves off a bridge
if they made book money.
Are you telling me the only people they want
to enjoy the movie are the people who read
the book?
Filmmakers can’t put everything from the
book into the movie.
Why does it matter if Hagrid is dragging a
tree.
What the f*ck is wrong with you?
I’ll tell you why.
Magic.
I’m watching a movie about magic and they’re
making this poor bastard drag a giant f*cking
tree all the way across campus.
Is he married to Darrin, from Bewitched?
Do they have some kind of a gay pact--
Why does the pact have to be gay?
--to not do magic?
Look, all this is explained--
In the book?
Yeah, well that’s another thing.
Why do I even care what you people who read
the book think?
You people are the hardest to please in the
world.
You nitpick everything.
Oh, they changed the boa constrictor to a
Burmese python!
Or they didn’t do Peeves the poltergeist!
Or they left out the Sorting Hat’s song!
But if I point out one inconsistency in the
movie, you tell me “Go read the book.”
Makes everything better, right?
Well, you wouldn’t ask as many stupid questions
after.
And while we’re on the subject of magic…
is it like the Force?
Do you have to believe you have it before
you actually have it?
I mean, they’re all sitting around waving
wands, doing this pseudo-Latin.
If it really comes down to who pronounces
it the best, aren’t they really just taking
language courses?
I think it’s like what Malcolm Gladwell
said.
It takes, like, 10,000 hours of practice to
become a master.
Well then Hermoine should be the best wizard
in the whole series.
All she ever does is read, study, correct
people, and go to the library.
She’s a better wizard than Ron.
She’s a better wizard than Harry.
She’s probably a better wizard than Dumbledore.
Dumbledore definitely has more than 10,000
hours of practice.
That’s why he does magic in one movie out
of eight.